doing this we are with a very happy
Victor of today's round Hans welcome
back to the studio another victory for
you and you prefaced it you said that
yeah in the last three rounds I'm going
to find this Ramon Tada let's just put
it that way how do you feel right now
it's yeah it's a pretty good game I was
impressed that he knew like everything
20 moves and I it's actually funny that
uh I wasn't sure if you knew that I had
a game here with black in the world of
rapid and Blitz against David Anton I
had a I can show you where it went off
sure after B4
I think I played A6 yes and uh so yeah
you can see it in this one and already
it's like yeah it's a big Advantage
already so I had I had analyzed that
after this game and I was like you just
knew it all I was not too happy uh at
least in this moment yeah yeah so this
is the mistake yeah this is what I so
United Faith he mentioned this after the
game I I remember there are some very
weird ways to to equalize this and yeah
this is just a completely ridiculous
like um not a faith I guess what did you
know about this position I knew it was
equal because I had as you saw I played
it so I analyzed this a bit from the
black side and I when he played um
Bishop G4 I was like why didn't I check
this like like if you go back Bishop G4
all the way yeah like when you play
Bishop G4 I'm like oh my God like how
stupid am I like uh he's he's been going
for let's say he's been playing slow
every game you know against Ray he
played sort of Knight C3 E6 94 Bishop G6
so I probably should have expected some
surprise in this love
um and I had some recent games here so
he could probably reasonably predict
what I would do but then I was like okay
well I remember this game that I played
I remember it's just incredibly
difficult so it turned out that he
didn't find this last Knight of faith
move
um yeah so but he was blitzing out by
the way at this point he had one hour
and 34. yeah but I think it's very easy
to mix these things
um so yeah F3 now I didn't know it but
it has to be the best move I know he
started thinking yes and that's usually
yeah yeah it's sort of uh and also
whenever you Blitz out the 20 moves of
theory it actually
um there's this sort of like inertia
effect where you feel like you keep
moving I've fallen victim to this myself
but sometimes when you Blitz out a lot
and then you mix it it can go really
badly because
when you don't realize you're in trouble
that's the worst type because you don't
you need you don't you're not as alert
so he probably was like okay
everything's okay and then yeah take one
I was very happy with this yep I think
you're something
96 yes okay this was very nice wow
okay Rook ff1
oh that is that is that is very smart
too just to get away from well just 97
H5 yeah or Bishop F7 oh yeah bishopstone
as well wow that is a nice little
prophylaxis I guess I need to go back to
the readings uh you know the Soviet
schools yeah yeah oh it's a DirecTV more
like prophylactic I think kramnik would
would find this move like that you know
so I guess I have to I I started reading
his biography it's quite good so I think
if I finish that I would have definitely
found it so I promise background yeah
yeah it's very good um but I haven't
finished it so
that that's that's my fault um but yeah
97 okay Rick H3 uh rookie I take yeah
okay let's go back yeah you should play
rookie fate I pointed this out yeah I
just thought he just has to be active
and again at Bishop F7 here he can just
play Rook f8 and take Knight D5 net of
four and it's the exact same concept in
the game uh after King takes E8
I cannot play
um I can't play Rook eat no I can't play
Rook E3 or rookie three also no King D7
is no wait where was it oh no sorry
sorry it is um uh instead of after A4
sorry after A4 yeah now King U7 I can't
play Bishop seven because Rooker fit and
then take that Defender yeah this is
this tactic
um but anyways just to interrupt you for
a second Wesley so did win his uh game
against elshon yeah let's keep going
yeah so um this was very interesting
yeah I thought I had pressure yep yes
okay King before I really like this move
um I felt like uh
well there's an idea to play take King
A5 King A6
yeah so this is so it's actually quite
interesting so what I was calculating
was let's say um he plays net of four
here as he as he did King H2 and let's
say rookie eight then I then I would
play then I can play them over uh PC
can't play King takes and then and then
King F5 oh my God yeah the engine's now
agreeing with me amazing before it
wasn't ring but now it's agreeing yeah
and then I thought this was incredibly
difficult because let's say Rook um is
even Rook B2 here right as a possibility
distance makes sense but also Rook D2
yes and I was looking at this and I
thought this was also incredibly
incredibly complex and uh we we played a
game uh
um uh
um in the summer no spring chest classic
and it was a very
it was a long end game so I felt you
know that this was like I felt like I
just need to like force him to calculate
and I thought that he would collapse so
it feels you know Alex quite yeah we've
actually uh he was actually one of the
first Grandmasters that I beat
um and not a feeder rated game but in a
G25 at the Marshall chess club I was
like 22.50 and his USF like 27 20 at the
time yeah and I beat him on the black
side of this like you know London King's
Indian setup and I was very proud of
that game
so yeah I've been playing Alex so
what do you feel his weaknesses are well
I've noticed just when it comes to in
this specific tournament there were just
the critical moments he was just making
a lot of blunders and when a lot of
pressure was just was was put
um the reviews collapsing at times so if
you look at I think his loss against
Fabi he played G8 yeah King G8 and then
who else did he lose to he lost to um
he's been very solid but maybe he's only
lost one game no no I'm pretty he's lost
two games he's minus one yeah yeah who
else did he lose to I don't remember
who was it it was was it a Wonder yes it
was a wonder and uh and he was also an
endgame slight pressure and the collapse
cam so I I felt the psychologically was
a very good choice and
um you know I wanted were you worried
that he put on the board 20 moves of
theory and he most likely will not get
it well I don't I don't think it was
that yeah the time trouble I would have
definitely liked um but I felt that in
this specific end game especially I
forgot F3 I was like okay I'm gonna
grind him down for for five hours here
and um eventually he should crack and
then okay in the game yes so let's look
okay let's go back this is already yeah
but there are some really interesting
yeah okay so yeah take Bishop takes yeah
Bishop A4 to sort of stop it so this is
five take critical moment yes yes you
could have one yeah King C8 what was the
plan here I wasn't I wasn't quite sure I
was like I was sort of
I felt to me that King theater King B8
was natural but
um yeah okay I can see Rick H1 is is an
interesting idea but I thought C6 no no
it makes sense but but I thought let's
say C6 sure
um yeah if you go here 65-24 and then
there's 58 yes but I thought um let's
say Bishop C6
um
uh 94 is the only move yeah and uh
this also didn't feel that simple to me
like take take King C5 I wasn't sure how
to evaluate this King D7
but then I guess yeah yeah okay okay so
maybe I'm just stupid yeah I guess King
theater is just important but again you
know I was
when I got C5 D6 I could feel the
momentum swinging you know any breaking
the eight yeah C6 yeah okay okay so was
King C5 a mistake no no okay because I'm
curious here so there's 94 King C6 and
G5 and now we're some very interesting
lines so yeah Rook B2 the point is
Knight takes D6 okay and uh okay ah so
yes I was I was correct yes okay and
then now King B7 and this is very weird
because I was thinking yeah King E7
and take take
this and and and uh take and then here I
wasn't sure oh my oh my gosh
okay I would have found it if I reached
this if I if I was forced to go down
this I'm sure would have found it
because I was going down okay here I was
calculating King B7 yes but then I
realized that um there's King D6
and if you take like just King C7 yeah
and then you sort of shut that down yeah
yeah Bishop B5 is crazy it's crazy he's
from a distance but when you're forced
to see it there's not really like an
alternative right yeah absolutely I
think uh sorry uh Hans we just last year
Mike we're gonna come back to you
forever and I was gonna say that Lanier
is actually doing pretty good against uh
Christopher you but let's jump back into
the studio with Hans all right uh that
Bishop B5 move guys by the way that's
just that's outrageous that's great yeah
I I don't think it's that difficult to
find if you force yourself to find it um
because you just have nothing else um
but let's because unfortunately on this
path um but there's also another moment
here I was if you go back there's
instead of G5 there was Rook H6 as well
instead of uh G5 Rook HC but I thought
the point was now be too thick and then
I go Rick D2 yes this is and then the
point is now if if uh G5 then I can just
take on G5 yeah and if it goes work H4
uh no no I mean instead of G5 uh then I
Then I then I have a take on T6 and then
I have um Bishop two King seven Bishop
D1
um oh no no there's actually four wait
no or oh sorry sorry yes it should be
three yeah
and then I thought that I'm sort of as
long as I don't lose this Pawn
which you probably don't I probably
shouldn't yeah
that's that's very clean that's very
clean yeah I was sort of worried about
this stuff but uh yeah this bishop B5 is
definitely the killer because that was
where I felt was the most critical and
then after that it was just it was just
a dead lost I guess Hans fifty percent
with two rounds to go how do you assess
your uh performance so far it's terrible
just ridiculous
one of my uh three loss of three wins
yes
yes oh my God
that's true lots of decisive trust
though no it's very bad um and
especially the fact that my three games
are lost I should have never lost like
there's it's not like uh these guys were
completely outplaying me brilliantly
it's was that I was just handing them uh
the win so a lot to learn but uh
considering the fact that I've won three
games I'm optimistic for my future guys
very good uh I'll look forward to uh the
last two rounds good luck uh in those
rounds just looking at